are you hearing from people in DC and  this question goes to everybody hearing  from people in DC about do they think  it's an accurate portrayal it's  obviously very silly yeah yeah I mean  since since we began airing really it's  I have friends who who work on the hill  who would say I feel like you just  pulled that from my office and there was  a there was a woman working with him who  thought that she was being bugged by us  because it was like all of her thoughts  and yeah everybody everybody that we've  yeah when we were at the Correspondents  Dinner is so bizarre because people  would come up to us I think guy come up  to me couldn't been 40 years old and it  was like 11:00 in the morning was like a  garden party and he he came up and he  said I think I'm a band  I said oh manic-depressive alcoholic you  know he was convinced that he was a bad  but it was like yeah  you